Okay.
Yeah,
there's all this Lindsay
shepherd that you're,
you're,
uh,
you know,
trans folk I a lot about
these issues in Sweden.
This one of the few that's sweetness
about it to slaughter activists.
And recently I wrote about how it
coincides with the autism diagnosis.
And I think it's the same
in the United States.
And it's,
I mean,
the number of,
especially young women who's never
had any doubts about their sexual,
about their gender identity,
but then they file,
find the like minded people with problems
connecting socially on the Internet.
And then all of a sudden
they decide that I'm,
I'm another woman,
I'm a man.
And they,
most of them have a diagnosis
within the autism spectrum.
And to even say this and say that this
is something we need to investigate is
sort of transphobia,
because then you're,
uh,
you're questioning the motives,
within the person.
So you,
you,
you're basically saying that it's not,
maybe it's not an gender
identity or feeling that full.
Well,
it's like maybe it's going to be worse.
Yeah,
well,
it's going to get worse because look like,
here's,
here's the logical fallacy.
Not all transsexuals have mental illness,
but many people with mental illness
are going to be confused about their
identity,
right?
So that the pool of people confused
about their identity is extraordinarily
large.
Now,
if you produce a social fad,
which is exactly what we're
doing with gender transformation,
then everyone who's unstable is going to
gravitate very rapidly towards that fat
that's happened many times with
different forms of pathology.
So for example,
there's a book called the discovery of
the unconscious by an existentialist
psychotherapist named Henri Aliber Shay,
which is a great book,
Great Book,
and he tracks the cyclical recurrence of
multiple personality disorder over the
last 300 years.
So a case will be reported
after everyone forgets about it.
For a generation or two,
a case will be reported and
then it spreads like wildfire.
And there's multiple
personality everywhere.
And then people get skeptical about it
and the reports dropoff to zero and it
goes underground again.
And then three generations again,
somebody reports a case history and Poof,
up it comes again.
And so the there,
there are these in Carl
Jung wrote about this a lot.
There are these psychic epidemics
that occur from time to time.
And,
uh,
the same thing happened for example,
in the 1980s when,
um,
there was a huge in the United
States in particular about,
uh,
satanistic ritual abuse in daycares and
that that produced an absolute uproar
for like five years and
many did you have that?
Yeah.
One of the professors
here at hope Sola tubes,
so university,
she wrote a book about
most of them men of power.
We're in Arlington Hospital.
Right,
right.
Uh,
even though it was,
I mean it's blatantly,
it's,
it's crazy.
Yeah.
But it wasn't gender scientists
because he would criticize
it was sort of a,
okay.
Yeah.
She,
she,
he's actually one of the
architects behind our,
uh,
how we view men's violence against women.
But you also wrote about this satanic
rituals that men in power had against
children,
but it wasn't in daycare.
It was just like against
children everywhere.
Ah,
AH,
yeah.
Yeah.
Well,
there's a great book written in the
United States called saint silence by a
social worker and the lawyer
that investigated that,
ah,
satanic ritual abuse epidemic.
And it makes the Salem witch
hunts looked like nothing.
I mean,
the longest prison sentence is in history,
were handed out for the
hypothetical perpetrators of
these satanic ritual abuse.
They dug under whole towns in places
looking for the tunnels where the,
where the sacrifices were being performed.
I mean,
they invented a whole new
categories of clinical diagnosis,
late onset,
female sexual predator,
of whom there are zero.
Right.
That is a category that does not exist.
Unbelievable.
It sounds like a great book.
I mean,
like a great horror horror movie or
something like be satanic circles,
but to actually believe in it,
this is,
it's really crazy.
Yep.